[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem elften elften
Norbert Lehmann ist auch dabei für den
Sport von mir und das sind die
wichtigsten Nachrichten Themen von heute
ukrainische Truppen erreichen herson
nach Monaten der Besatzung ist die
Gebietshauptstadt im Süden offenbar
wieder unter ukrainischer Kontrolle
Schluss mit der
corona-isolationspflicht das verkünden
vier Bundesländer ein Fehler meint der
Bundesgesundheitsminister
und beiden auf der Weltklimakonferenz
der US-Präsident sieht das Überleben des
Planeten in Gefahr und verspricht die
Klimaziele der USA einzuhalten
als Russland vorgestern ankündigte seine
Truppen aus herson abzuziehen
beherrschte ziemliche Skepsis in der
Ukraine erst vor einem Monat hatte der
russische Präsident herrson
völkerrechtlich annektiert der Rückzug
gilt als Blamage für Putin doch jetzt
wird in der Region gefeiert denn
tatsächlich sind die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte bis nach herson vorgerückt
und Moskau hat nach eigenen Angaben alle
30.000 seiner Soldaten dort auf die
östliche Seite des nipro zurückgezogen
Kristina gründgen fasst zusammen
sie jubeln schwenken ukrainische Fahnen
und fallen den ankommenden Soldaten
begeistert in die Arme der Triumphen
wird gefeiert auch in den sozialen
Medien die Skepsis der vergangenen Tage
ob die Russen tatsächlich aus der Stadt
und der Region abziehen war ich der
Euphorie
diese Bilder sollen zeigen wie ein Teil
der russischen Soldaten den Fluss nipro
überquerte zu Fuß über eine schwimmende
Behelfsbrücke der Abzug sei
abgeschlossen so das russische
Verteidigungsministerium
nicht ein einziges Teil militärischer
Ausrüstung wurde zurückgelassen alle
russischen Soldaten haben den Fluss
überquert
doch bei aller Freude Gerüchte das
womöglich doch bis zu mehrere tausend
Russen in Hessen zurückgeblieben sein
bereiten auch ukrainischen offiziellen
Sorge
viele Russen konnten den den nipro nicht
überqueren sie werfen ihre Uniformen weg
ziehen Zivilkleidung an und versuchen
sich zu verstecken sie werden
Provokationen in Hessen vorbereiten es
gibt noch viel zu tun
die Behelfsbrücke über den Fluss liegt
heute in Trümmern genau wie die schon
länger beschädigte große Brücke daneben
ein weiteres Symbol für einen der
größten Rückschläge für Russland seit
Beginn des Krieges fragen wir daran
Hasans HD er war in der Region wie sehr
traut die ukrainische Armee diesem
Rückzug heraus
ja die ukrainische Armee bleibt bei
ihrem vorsichtigten Vorgehen zur Stunde
geht geht die Militärpolizei von Haus zu
Haus kontrolliert Ausweise sie suchen
Kollaborateure und auch womögliche
russische Soldaten sie hat auch gewarnt
die Armee dass Menschen jetzt schon auf
die Idee kommen sollten zurückzukehren
nach kerson das wäre sei viel zu früh
und viel zu gefährlich aber genau das
sehen sich natürlich die Menschen die
monatelang getrennt waren von ihren
Verwandten und Freunden und es ist hart
für Sie dass Sie sich jetzt noch
gedulden müssen danke für diese
Einschätzung daran
mit den mutmaßlichen Hintergründen der
Truppenverschiebungen beschäftigt sich
ab 19.30 Uhr auch unser Format heute
live auf ZDF heute und den Social Media
Kanälen
jetzt zu Corona und der Frage wie viel
Maßnahmen braucht es noch vier
Bundesländer planen weitreichende
Lockerungen konkret wollen Bayern
Baden-Württemberg Hessen und
Schleswig-Holstein die isolationspflicht
aufheben bisher müssen infizierte
mindestens fünf Tage zu Hause bleiben
Cornelia Strauß berichtet
ab kommenden Mittwoch müssen sich
Menschen hier in Bayern nicht mehr
isolieren wenn das Ergebnis ihres
corona-tests positiv ist außerhalb ihrer
Wohnungen müssen sie dann lediglich eine
Maske tragen gegenüber vulnerablen
Gruppen im medizinischen oder
pflegerischen Einrichtungen wird weiter
ein
betretungs-verbot geben weil wir die
natürlich besonders schützen möchten
viele Mediziner können die Entscheidung
nachvollziehen durch eine gestiegene
Immunkompetenz der Bevölkerung Seiko
wird 19 mittlerweile mit anderen
Atemwegserkrankungen vergleichbar
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach teilt diese Auffassung nicht
wir haben derzeit etwa 1000 Todesfälle
durch koved pro Woche wir sind vor einer
wahrscheinlich schweren winterwelle weil
die bq1.1 Variante sich stärker
ausbreitet wir müssen auch bedenken dass
viele Menschen im Arbeitsprozess wenn
sie sich infizieren
long-zahlen begrenzen und die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
schützen und nicht gefährden wenn mit
leitende infiziert sind aber nicht krank
wer entscheidet ob sie zur Arbeit kommen
sollen oder nicht die Aufhebung der
isolationspflicht stellt Arbeitgeber vor
neue Herausforderungen ich muss die
betrieblichen Belange also meine
Fürsorgepflicht die ich nach wie vor
natürlich jetzt erst recht als
Arbeitgeber habe abwägen mit dem
Belangen der Belegschaft ich muss den
Gesundheitsschutz neu prüfen und ich
muss mich gegebenenfalls mit dem
Betriebsrat also der
Arbeitnehmervertretung neu einig unklar
ist auch was das nun für Berufspendler
zwischen den Bundesländern bedeutet wenn
dort unterschiedliche Regelungen gelten
sie gilt als eine der wichtigsten und
längsten Sitzungen im Bundestag wenn der
Haushaltsausschuss darum ringt welches
Ministerium im kommenden Jahr wie viel
Geld für was bekommt jetzt steht der
Haushalt 2023 allerdings macht der Bund
deutlich mehr Schulden als geplant Karl
Hinterleitner berichtet es geht ums Geld
es geht um die Energiekrise und die
Folgen für das Land nach 18 Stunden
Beratung des Haushaltsausschusses kamen
in letzter Minute noch einmal
zusätzliche Milliarden für den
Schienenverkehr und Ukraine Hilfen oben
drauf am Ende steht eine neue
Rekordsumme der Haushalt für 2023
beträgt nun
476,3 Milliarden Euro davon sind 45,6
Milliarden neue Kredite mehr als doppelt
so viel wie geplant der Finanzminister
ist dennoch zufrieden der Haushalt 2023
hält erstens die Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes ein
zweitens realisieren wir
rekordverdächtig hohe Investitionen und
zum in der dritten entlasten wir die
Breite Mitte unseres Landes die
Opposition sieht das anders und spricht
von Trickserei wir haben auch den
Eindruck dass die Schuldenbremse nur
Farbe gilt und der Finanzminister
versucht ja mit Taschenspielertricks die
Schuldenbremse zu umgehen sehen wir ja
auch an dem Sondervermögen die wie Pilze
aus dem Boden schießen tatsächlich
tauchen 8,9 Milliarden aus dem
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr 80 Milliarden
aus dem Klima vor und 165 Milliarden
hilfs- und energiemaßnahmen aus dem
Stabilitätsfonds im Haushalt gar nicht
auf wenn man die Summen zusammenziehen
sind das 300 Milliarden neue Schulden im
nächsten Jahr die dann auch tatsächlich
aufgenommen werden und das ist schon
eine horrende Zahl gewaltige Summen vor
allem um die Folgen des Krieges und der
Krise ums Gas abzufedern ob dafür das
Geld dann am Ende wirklich ausreicht was
heute noch niemand ganz genau
nun ist es fix die letzten drei
Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland bleiben
dreieinhalb Monate länger im Betrieb als
ursprünglich geplant der Bundestag
stimmte der Vorlage von Bundeskanzler
Scholz zu die Betroffenen AKW in Bayern
Baden-Württemberg und Niedersachsen
sollen bis April 2023 Strom produzieren
und so für eine Entlastung des
Strommarkts in der Energiekrise sorgen
obwohl die Auswirkungen des Klimawandels
mittlerweile für alle spürbar sind geht
der Ausstoß des Klimakillers CO2
ungebremst weiter in diesem Jahr
erwarten Forscher einen neuen Rekordwert
am meisten Kohlendioxid stößt China aus
mit einem Anteil von fast 31 Prozent an
den globalen Emissionen auf Platz 2
Folgen die USA mit 13,5 Prozent
entsprechend groß sind die Erwartungen
auf der Weltklimakonferenz in Ägypten
welche Pläne der US-Präsident im Gepäck
hat goldene atai
bla bla bla schluss mit den leeren reden
fordern klimaaktivisten Washington der
größte Verschmutzer der Atmosphäre solle
den meist Betroffenen
Entwicklungsländern endlich
schadenersatzzusagen
später als alle anderen Staatschefs
trifft Joe Biden ein aber wenigstens ist
er gekommen anders als die Präsidenten
Chinas und Russlands bleibt seine Rede
symbolisch oder kommt er den bitten auf
der deutschen klimabeauftragten nach
mehr zu zahlen und Afrika zu helfen
vergangenes Jahr setzte ich mich dafür
ein mit dem Kongress unsere
klimaunterstützung zur vervierfachen und
jährlich 11 Milliarden Dollar
bereitzustellen bis 2024 ich werde
kämpfen um zu sehen wie diese Klimaziele
finanziert werden können
doch alles kämpfen ist vergeblich wenn
der US-Kongress nun eine republikanische
Mehrheit bekommt dann wird es weitaus
weniger Geld für das Klima geben
versteht das amerikanische Volk nicht
weil es mit dem Planeten passiert fragen
sich Afrikaner hier
die Überflutungen die dürren in dieser
Realität lebt die Jugend Afrikas die USA
und andere Reiche Nationen die
Reparationen leisten können müssen es
hier und jetzt auf dieser Konferenz tun
beidens Anspruch auf eine globale
klimaführerschaft sie hängt davon ab ob
die USA für die Klimaschäden der ärmsten
aufkommen oder alle Bemühungen dafür
blockieren
bringt diese Klimakonferenz etwas für
den Klimaschutz das war eine der Frage
Fragen beim Politbarometer Antje Pieper
hat Antworten und an jeder gibt es klare
Mehrheiten ja deutliche 90 Prozent
glauben dass dort wenig oder überhaupt
nichts für den Klimaschutz erreicht wird
zu klären aber gibt es sicher viel so
sind fast drei Viertel der Befragten der
Meinung die Industriestaaten sollen den
ärmeren Ländern mehr zahlen damit diese
die Folgen des Klimawandels besser
bewältigen können 20% sind dagegen
blickt man auf den Klimaschutz in
Deutschland so sind die allermeisten der
Meinung Politik und Unternehmen machen
zu wenig die Befragten sind aber auch
selbstkritisch 63% meinen die Bürger
selbst machen zu wenig
schauen wir aufs Personal zum ersten Mal
ist Außenministerin baerbock die
beliebteste Politikerin wie sieht es mit
den Parteien aus ja es gibt weiter keine
Mehrheit für die Ampel und auch sonst
zeigt sich die Zufriedenheit mit der
Arbeit der Regierung ist weiter gering
wenn am Sonntag wirklich Bundestagswahl
wäre käme die SPD auf 19 Prozent die
Union liegt vorn in der Wählergunst bei
28% bei der unverändert die Grünen legen
etwas zu 22 FDP etwas weniger 5 die auf
der AFD bleibt bei 15 und die Linke bei
5%. ganz kurz noch Fußball wie stehen
die Befragten zur WM in Katar also von
Euphorie ist der wenig zu spüren im
Gegenteil eine Mehrheit findet es nicht
richtig dass die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft an der WM teilnimmt
Dankeschön Antje Pieper das komplette
Politbarometer können Sie um heute
journal sehen um 10 oder jederzeit bei
uns online
wegen zahlreicher Pannen soll die
Bundestagswahl in Berlin teilweise
wiederholt werden das hat der Bundestag
entschieden bei der Wahl im vergangenen
Jahr hatten sich zum Teil lange
Schlangen vor den Wahllokalen gebildet
weil es dort nicht genug Stimmzettel gab
auch wegen des berlin-marathons der am
selben Tag stattfand jetzt soll in rund
einem Fünftel aller Wahlbezirke noch mal
gewählt werden wann ist aber noch unklar
die Zahl der Menschen die illegal nach
Deutschland einreisen ist weiter
gestiegen mit Gund gut 75.000
Grenzübertritten bisher liege der Wert
schon jetzt über den Zahlen des
Vorjahres teilte die Bundespolizei mit
Kontrollen etwa zu Österreich sollen
deshalb verlängert werden Ukrainer sind
in den Zahlen nicht berücksichtigt sie
dürfen derzeit generell legal einreisen
auch übers Mittelmeer kommen wieder mehr
Flüchtlinge in die EU und direkt kocht
der Streit über die Verteilung wieder
hoch Italiens neue Regierung weigerte
sich das Rettungsschiff Ocean Viking an
einem italienischen Hafen anlegen zu
lassen es musste nach Frankreich
ausweichen jetzt droht Paris mit
Gegenmaßnahmen Anne Arendt und Thomas
Walde berichten ein rettender Hafen nach
knapp drei Wochen auf hoher See die
Ocean Viking steuert am Morgen Toulon in
Südfrankreich an bringt 230 Migranten an
Land das ist eine ausnahmeentscheidung
die wir nur aufgrund der zunehmend
schlechteren Zustände an Bord getroffen
haben so mussten wir bereits vier
Passagiere per Rettungshubschrauber
abtransportieren
ein humanitärer Akt Hilfe in einer
Notsituation doch die Rechten im Land
sehen darin einen Dammbruch
das ist nur der Beginn einer ganzen
Serie von Schiffen der
Hilfsorganisationen die nun Einlass in
unsere französischen Häfen verlangen
werden
doch nicht nur innenpolitisch brandet
der streitumasylfragen damit neu auf der
Fall liegt vor allem den rechten
Kurswechsel Italiens offen das Land das
nach internationalem Recht eigentlich
zuständig gewesen wäre hatte seine Häfen
dicht gemacht
Frankreichs Regierung wirft der
italienischen vor sich in human
Verhalten und Menschen in Not im Stich
gelassen zu haben im Gegenzug will
Frankreich nun die geplante Aufnahme von
3.500 Flüchtlingen aus Italien erst
einmal aussetzen so führt der Fall der
Ocean Viking zu einer diplomatischen
Krise in der EU italiens Regierungschef
in Meloni weist alle Schuld von sich
beklagt den aggressiven Ton andere
Länder darunter Deutschland haben
bereits angekündigt einen Teil der
Flüchtlinge der Ocean Viking aufzunehmen
beigelegt ist damit das Tauziehen in
Europas Asylpolitik noch lange nicht
nach Thüringen dort sollen
Landesbehörden in der offiziellen
Kommunikation keine gender-sternchen und
ähnliches mehr verwenden das hat der
Landtag auf Initiative der CDU
beschlossen da es sich aber nur um eine
Empfehlung und nicht um ein Gesetz
handelt ist die rot-rot-grüne
Minderheitsregierung daran rechtlich
nicht gebunden
eine Gedenkstätte bei Potsdam erinnert
ab heute an die in Afghanistan getöteten
Soldaten im Beisein von Hinterbliebenen
eröffnete Verteidigungsministerin
Lambrecht den Ehrenhain und nannte ihn
den emotionalsten Ort der Bundeswehr das
Herzstück ist ein 27 Tonnen schwere
Felsblock aus Afghanistan 59 Soldaten
verloren bei dem Einsatz ihr Leben er
endete im vergangenen Sommer nach fast
20 Jahren
der CSU-Generalsekretär Martin Huber
verzichtet künftig auf das Tragen seines
Doktortitels er zieht damit die
Konsequenz aus einer Prüfung seiner
Dissertation durch die
Ludwig-Maximilians-Universität in
München der Bericht sah zwar keine
Beweise für eine bewusste Täuschung
stellte aber fest dass Hubers Arbeit
wissenschaftlichen Standards nicht
entspricht
und dann war da noch was heute am 11.11
um 11 Uhr ging es los Karnevalsbeginn
mit Alaaf oder Helau ins Getümmel
endlich wieder ohne
corona-beschränkungen und auch wenn die
halbe Republik jedes Jahr wieder die
stirnrunzelt über das seltsam bunte
Treiben am Rhein die Narren und
nährenden verteidigen es als Feier des
Lebens Dominik müller-
drei zwei eins
der Countdown wie immer der Jubel
vielleicht einen Tick ausgelassener als
sonst nach zweieinhalb Jahren Pandemie
in denen der Karneval gar nicht oder nur
eingeschränkt stattfand endlich wieder
feiern wie früher
[Musik]
einen Tag alle Sorgen vergessen und nur
feiern und Spaß haben auch in Mainz auch
in Düsseldorf heute buntes Treiben ohne
corona-beschränkungen Virologen
beobachten dass die Politik dass die
Menschen mittlerweile bereit sein die
Risiken in Kauf zu nehmen dennoch
warnende Worte vor allem da man noch zu
wenig über longkowit-wisse
und solange das noch nicht gegeben ist
ist meiner Meinung nach das ganze etwas
zu freizügig und wir sind zu früh dran
um zur Normalität zurückzukehren in Köln
feiert der Karneval 200-jähriges
Jubiläum und hier betonen die Ecken wie
wichtig die fünfte Jahreszeit ist gerade
in schweren Zeiten angesichts von
Pandemie Krieg und wirtschaftlichen
Nöten ja gerade in dieser Zeit muss
meiner sollte man Karneval feiern in der
Karneval hat den Menschen immer Hoffnung
gegeben es war also meine Oma damals war
es nicht anders nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg als Rosenmontag wird bestimmt
durch die Stadt gezogen ist das gab den
neuen Menschen immer Hoffnung das Leben
feiern trotz und wegen der vielen Krisen
im Rheinland sind diesem Ruf heute
zehntausende gefolgt
[Applaus]
feiern kann auch die
Fußballnationalmannschaft der Frauen
toller Sieg gestern ne ja eigentlich ja
nur eine Freundschaftsspiel aber wenn
man die Weltmeisterin aus den USA in den
USA 2:1 schlägt ja dann ist das schon
ein echter Prestige Erfolg denn das Team
um Superstar margaretino das war zuvor
71 Heimspiele infolge umgeschlagen
Freude und jubeln nach dem 2:1 Sieg der
aber schwer erkämpft war die USA zuerst
das bessere Team doch die Führung nach
51 Minuten für Deutschland Klara Bühl
mit etwas Glück danach die Gäste stärker
aber die US-Amerikanerinnen erzielten
den Ausgleich durch Megan repino der
Superstar zuvor eingewechselt so auch
Paulina Krumbiegel Comeback nach
Kreuzbandriss und Torschützen zum 2:1
für Deutschland
ja überhaupt zu spielen dann daneben der
Mannschaft nur noch zum Sieg zu
verhelfen ist einfach echt ein geiles
Gefühl am Sonntag gibt es bereits den
nächsten Härtetest gegen die USA
deutsche Superfrauen also in den USA und
amerikanische Supermänner in Deutschland
Training der Tampa Bay backen-news mit
Football Megastar Tom Brady in München
dort am Sonntag das erste NFL Spiel in
Deutschland die Bugs gegen die Seattle
Seahawks vor 67.000 Zuschauern ja über 3
Millionen Kartenanfragen von football
fans soll es gegeben haben
zur Fußball-WM kritische Stimmen zu
Katar gibt es zu Hauf jetzt hat die FIFA
eine menschenrechtsaktion des dänischen
Nationalteams untersagt
Menschenrechte für alle darf nicht auf
den offiziellen wm-trainingstrikots der
Dänen stehen der dänische Fußballverband
hatte im Zuge der WM schon früh
kritische Botschaften angekündigt ein
anderer Weg ihres Protests ist da
subtiler das dritte Ausweichtrikot ist
ganz in schwarz gehalten soll die
während der Bauarbeiten in Katar
Verstorbenen Arbeiter Ehren dabei
präsentiert die FIFA auf ihrer Webseite
medienwirksam selbst ihre Werte
verpflichtet sich die Menschenrechte
noch stärker in ihre führungs- und
Entscheidungsstruktur zu integrieren was
geschieht wenn ein Spieler sich in Katar
kritisch äußert ist unklar Manuel Neuer
kündigte Kritik an ein vorsichtiges
Zeichen der deutschen bislang die
Kapitänsbinde zeigt die Worte One Love
und farbige Streifen zwar aber eben
nicht in Regenbogen
über ein Zeichen kommt ja vielleicht
auch noch ein bisschen mehr schaumarbeit
Dankeschön danke das Wochenende bringt
ruhiges Herbstwetter wo die Sonne den
Nebel verdrängt erfahren Sie gleich von
Katja horneffer Marietta Slomka freut
sich auf Sie im heute-journal um 10 und
wir freuen uns wenn Sie morgen wieder
dabei sind ein schönes Wochenende ihnen
machen sie es gut auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend auch heute hielten sich
Nebel und hochnebelsäge zum Beispiel an
der Donau am Main oder auch am Rhein und
diese Nebelfelder werden sich in der
Nacht wieder verdichten und auch weiter
ausbreiten über Süddeutschland im Norden
ist es meist klar und an der Ostsee
ziehen dichtere Wolkenfelder vorbei an
der See sinken die Temperaturen auf 11
bis 6 Grad sonst geht die Temperaturen
auf +5 bis -2 Grad zurück und die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen sind ganz
unterschiedlich wenn sich der Nebel zäh
hält dann steigen die Werte kaum auf 7
Grad mit leichter Föhn Unterstützung am
Nordrand von Harz oder Eifel gibt es bei
strahlendem Sonnenschein bis zu 17 Grad
und in Norddeutschland gibt es morgen
viel Sonnenschein an der Ostsee noch
dichtere Wolkenfelder und im Süden wird
das eine zähe Angelegenheit ob sich
Nebel und Hochnebel auflösen nicht
überall wird das bis zum Abend klappen
am Sonntag wird es langsam spannender
das liegt an diesem Tief hier mit dem
zentralen Mittelmeer denn das zieht
weiter nach Nordwesten bringt dann regen
auch bei uns in Deutschland am Montag im
Südwesten dieser Regen zieht dann am
Dienstag weiter nordwärts es bleibt aber
vorerst noch mild bei 7 bis 17 Grad
guten Abend